there are there are a lot of good
reasons to not be very excited about the
fact that Bernie Sanders is running for
president again he just announced today
officially that he's running for
president it's gonna make another run at
it and there are plenty of reasons to
not support his run
he's a nutty socialist for one that's
probably the main thing but his age also
does matter okay age is not just a
number age is a physiological reality
okay it's it's not-it's not just oh age
is just a number no no it's it's it's
more than that it represents the the
amount of time that you've spent on
earth and unfortunately in a you know in
a reality where only death and taxes are
certain it means that as we embark on
this inevitable unceasing march towards
our own demise and as we get closer to
it we start to break down physically it
just it happens there but it's happening
meat to me right now I'm only 32 it's
happening already I'm already doing the
thing at 32 where you you know you you
walk into a room and then you you can't
remember why you walked into the room or
where you're looking for your phone and
then you tell someone to call your phone
and then you look at your hand and
realize oh I was holding it the whole
time so I'm or I'm already doing that at
32 Sanders is 77 he'll be 79 in 2020 so
if you were to win the presidency which
of course he won't but if he did he
would be 79 at that point the average
age of death for Americans is 78 which
is actually a lot lower than I thought
I thought we were in the I thought we
were in the 80s but apparently were at
78 so just putting that in perspective
that at 79 you're already on borrowed
time statistically speaking at 79 you
simply do not have the mental or
physical capacity to take on the most
demanding and stressful job in the world
and and that's not sort of sign the
insults just just just a reality of it
look at you know I mean look at a
picture of Barack Obama when he first
in the office as a relatively young man
verse when he came out eight years later
or bore George Bush I mean you see what
it did what eight years Minh the White
House does to a person I mean it's like
when you're in the White House you're on
dog years basically every year is seven
years of stress so if you know so George
Bush went in in is whatever 50s he came
out he was like eighty and so when if if
Bernie Sanders wins the presidency which
again he won't but if he did when he
gets out he'll be two hundred and
seventy five years old really so it's
just look when you're seventy nine how
arrogant this is my problem with it how
arrogant and how power-hungry and just
eat a testicle and self-obsessed do you
have to be to run for president when
you're 79 I mean just go home and retire
go be with your family go fishing or
something
you're 79 but you're so desperate for
power you you you you you cannot imagine
existence without without power and
pursuing more power and that's how
desperate you are for it that you are
that you will you will even keep younger
and healthier people out of office just
so that you can sit on the throne even
if you die on the throne you just want
to feel it you just want to be on it
what kind of arrogance is that really
just step aside already let it go go
home the the Democratic you know
presidential field is going to be filled
with people like this people in their in
their you know older people and they're
set in Joe Biden Bernie Sanders who
knows maybe Hillary Clinton will run
again just people who can't let it go
already go home and enjoy the rest of
your life
that's my problem
it's it's arrogant all right so
things I want to talk about today I
don't wanna spend a lot of time on
Bernie Sanders well we'll move on from
that already the media you know likes to
to credit itself with having courage
journalists like to pretend that they
have a lot of courage but I think that
courage is is actually the probably the
most wrongly attributed and least often
actually demonstrated virtue in modern
society so in other words it's a virtue
that we're all we're always attributing
to people and to actions but very often
we do so wrongly and it's kind of rare
that we act that we see real actual
courage so for instance a journalist who
stands up against Trump Jim Acosta doing
one of his show a little things at a
press conference taking it to Donald
Trump
now these they might get credit for that
from other people in the media for being
courageous but that's not courageous
because you're doing something that
everybody else in your profession will
agree with and admire you for so it
doesn't mean that you shouldn't stand up
against politicians and powerful people
if you're if you're a journalist you
should do it the way Jim Acosta does but
in general in principle that is a good
thing to do I'm just saying that when
the when the politician is a Republican
and you're in the media well right or
wrong you know that when you take him to
task all of your friends and and all of
your colleagues are going to agree with
you so it doesn't take courage to do it
but a journalist standing up against
other journalists okay well now that
takes courage which brings us to Laura
Logan who was a reporter she was on a
podcast called Mike drop with retired
Navy SEAL Mike Ritland this weekend and
she's a reporter I believe for CBS
during the course of that discussion she
called her own profession to task and
she's began a lot of attention for this
over the last day or two I think rightly
so let me just read a couple of a a few
of the lines here from her interview
some of the things that you said you
said the media everywhere is mostly
liberal not just in the US but in this
country eighty-five percent of
journalists are registered Democrats
that's just a fact no one is registering
Democrat when they're really Republican
so the facts are on the side that you
just stated most journalists are left or
liberal or Democrat whatever words you
want to give it how do you know you're
being lied to
how do you know you're being manipulated
how do you know there's nothing there's
something not right with the coverage
when they simplify it all and there's no
gray there's no gray it's all one-way
well life isn't like that if it doesn't
match real life it's probably not
there's something wrong she's saying so
for example all the coverage on Trump
all the time is negative that's
distortion of the way things go in real
life because although the media has
historically always been left-leaning
we've abandoned our pretense or at least
the effort to be objective and she goes
on to talk about how the media has
become political activists and she and
you may even use the word propagandist
she uses she says now none of that is
news to anyone right but I think it's
worth paying attention to
well number one because when somebody in
the profession is telling you this then
you know it's true because she's got no
reason to say this if it wasn't true and
also it takes guts and integrity for
someone in that world to say it see when
you actually risk something when you put
something on the line when speaking
truth will cost you something something
real something tangible when you could
actually be tangibly palpably hurt in
some way by spy speaking the truth well
then that's when it's courageous to do
it so good for Laura Logan on the other
end of the spectrum so that's what
courage looks like a
fortunately a rare example of it but
let's look at some examples of cowardice
which is something in far greater supply
we have a surplus of cowardice in our
culture and so we have a very cowardly
display from Democrats and a lot of
people in the media who are trying to
play clean up now and trying to save
face
after the smollett thing blew up and
humiliated them but they're not doing a
very good job of it
for instance both Kamala Harris and Cory
Booker you may remember when the news
broke about about about Jesse Smollett
with when the fake news broke when he
came out with his with his whole made-up
story
within hours Kamala Harris and Cory
Booker both came out and they both use
the exact same phrase they said it's a
it's a modern day lynching as a phrase
they use they called it a lynching and
they went on to talk about how this is
hatred and bigotry and so on and so
forth but now suddenly now that the
story has shifted
Kemal Harris said Cory Booker that now
there become now they're getting more
cautious and they want to be more
thoughtful and they want to make wait
for the facts to come in so let me show
you this is a clip of Camilla Harris
when remember what she said she
originally called it a a a modern day
lynching but then yesterday she was
asked again about small it kind of a
follow up like hey what do you think now
and this is what she said which tweet
what we are about saying that it is a
modern day lynching that
sorry Jesse small in okay so I will say
this about that case I think that the
facts are still unfolding and I'm very
concerned about obviously okay so she's
very flustered there and by the way that
shows you you see there it shows you
that Camille Harris as a Liberal
Democrat she is she is not used to being
challenged at all by the media and she
is not at used to being asked difficult
questions which this shouldn't even be a
difficult question this is just hey you
made this comment two weeks ago more
facts have come out what do you think
now so it's not even if it's uneven
telling a gotcha question it's a very
fair basic question that as a politician
she should absolutely be prepared to
answer but she wasn't prepared to answer
that question she didn't think she be
asked it because this is the media right
they're supposed to help her you know
there's they're supposed to be friends
with theirs they're supposed to be her
friends her PR team and she was asked
that question she was she was flummoxed
um Booker was not quite as flummoxed but
just as cowardly here's here's Booker's
answer when he was asked to follow up on
his modern day lynching phrase well the
information feel coming out I'm gonna
withhold until all the information
actually comes out from on the record
sources okay so both of them now are
saying well well well let's let's let's
wait let's hold off let's wait for more
facts to come in I just want you to
appreciate the irony here when no facts
had been it there were when there were
no facts when no facts had come in when
we knew nothing and there was no
evidence of anything either way both
Harrison Booker were ready to call it a
lynching and go into a whole spiel about
hatred and bigotry but now that there
are facts now they don't want to say
anything
so when note and when no facts were in
they didn't want to wait for the facts
and now that we have a bunch of facts
now they want to wait for more facts
before they say anything else right okay
meanwhile like we talked about yesterday
the media is
so trying to back away from this and a
plate of public lips on the show
yesterday of the media doing their own
kind of Camilla Harris impression and
sort of stammering and yammering and
trying to find a way around this tried
to explain that no really they were they
reported this fairly all along you know
they they weren't you know Hollywood
celebrities and maybe politicians okay
they jumped on the bandwagon to world
but not the media no we we didn't do
anything wrong we were we were you know
we're the courageous truth seeking
fact-finding journalists and we could
never be guilty of reporting fake news
no fake news that's a that's an
offensive slur that Donald Trump use
that that's that that's it's not fair we
we don't engage in fake news that's what
they're claiming but I thought it could
be worth while before they stuff their
own reporting down the memory hole which
they're attempting to do right now it
could be worthwhile to catalogue some of
the headlines from the days immediately
following the attack so I ought to give
you a brief sampling just so we remember
you know how they how they really did
handle this despite what they're
claiming now and so I'm not gonna read
you tweets from celebrities and
politicians these are reputable news
outlets and these are some of the
headlines so from from the first few
days after the supposed attack so this
from CNN CNN Headline empire star jussie
Smollett attacked in possible hate crime
and there were identical headlines that
could be found in The Hollywood Reporter
and deadlines in other places now notice
something that's it's it's sort it's not
very subtle but it's a little subtle
because the word possible is in there
but look at where they put that
qualifier of possible empire star jussie
Smollett attacked in attacked in
possible hate crime
so there's only uncertainty around the
motivation it's a possible hate crime
but the attack itself is reported as
fact you know there's a there
there's a big difference between empire
star jussie Smollett possibly attacked
in hate crime and Empire Star justice
Millette attacked impossible hate crime
there's a big difference between those
two headlines and the media knows that
the New York Times says Jesse Smollett
star of Empire attacked in what police
call a possible hate crime yet again now
this is this is totally intentional okay
it's it's it is manipulative it is
completely intentional when they are
making this headline they know that most
people only read the headline especially
in this day and age of social media and
everything people are just scrolling
down social media they're seeing the
headlines and they're getting input
their impression of what's going on so
even if they use more cautious wording
in the text of the article it's the
headline that matters and there's a
conscious decision here to not put a
word like possible or alleged or
reported or suppose it or whatever in
front of attacked because they want you
to think that that was an actual effect
the AP this was their headline Jesse
Smollett strikes emotional chord
attackers won't win now this headline
could have been written by small it's
just hired defense attorneys this is
just pure propaganda pure PR for for
justice Millette and the word alleged
appears nowhere in the in the in the
headline it also appears nowhere in the
text of that particular article by the
way from from Variety Chicago PD's
seeking persons of interest in justice
Millette attack manager was on phone
during incident yet again no alleged no
indication of of any kind of skepticism
just reported as fact
Forbes headline Empire actor Jesse's
mullet issues statement after a vicious
attack I'm okay now this one I love
because the folks over at Forbes they
knew
they had to put some kind of qualifying
word in front of attack right they
needed something there they couldn't
just say attack so they were thinking
should we put alleged there or possible
or report it or mineral let's put
vicious in front of it so this is what
this is what the media does now consider
consider for a second how these
headlines would look if a conservative
let's just take a very similar kind of
incident but change the politics around
a little bit and the racial dynamics so
consider how the headlines would look if
a if a conservative Hollywood actor like
let's say Dean Cain okay
what if he claimed that he was jumped by
two liberal black men in Elizabeth
Warren for president t-shirts who were
shouting leftist slogans as they stomped
him half to death and imagine that he
that he said that this this suppose an
assault happened in Huntsville Alabama
Warren country as the attacker
supposedly shouted as they were stopping
him and there are no witnesses of it
there's no footage to confirm the story
but that's his story it is inconceivable
that CNN or the New York Times or the AP
would publish headlines like this if
they reported the claim at all it would
be conveyed with extreme extreme and
warranted skepticism and we all know
that of course and so it gets redundant
after a while to point it out but I
think we do have to point it out and we
do have to keep pointing to the truth as
the media tries to bear it bury it
alright enough about Smollett here's a
wresting story out of Lawton child's
middle academy in lakeland florida the
story that you may have seen yesterday
again if you're just reading the
headlines the story was that a middle
school kid a sixth grader was arrested
for refusing to stand for the Pledge of
Allegiance before school and that was
what was going viral in social media and
everything that a kid was arrested for
refusing to stand for the pledge but and
and and by the way yet again when I was
on Twitter I saw all kinds of people
posting about this story or you know
just retweeting a headline they had
headline and some from some news outlet
about how a kid was arrested for
refusing to stand for the pledge and you
know people retweeting the headline with
a little caption saying how insane this
is and I thought this is America and
blah blah blah it's like people never
learn or I mean how many times we just
went through this with the smollett
thing how many times we have to go
through this before people learn you you
need to read the story for yourself you
cannot come to any conclusions at all
based on headlines if all you've read is
the headline then you should not be
saying anything about the story publicly
you should be posting about it you
should be retweeting it you shouldn't be
offering your opinion because you don't
know anything about it all you read is a
headline and the headlines can be and
often are and are at this point almost
certain to be misleading how is it that
people still don't understand this
because with this story if you would
just read actually click on the stupid
little headline and read the article
you'll find that there is more to the
story the kid was not arrested for
refusing to stand for the pledge that is
not the story that is not true let me
read a bit from Emily zanotti story in
The Daily wire so as a sixth grader in
Florida was reportedly arrested after he
refused to participate in a class
recitation the Pledge of
a move a move which escalated into a
confrontation with police and school
officials according to local news
sources media and Lakeland Florida
reported that the 11-year old a student
at a Lawton child's middle academy
called the flag racist and described the
national anthem as offensive though the
national anthem was not being played at
the time a substitute teacher who was
minding the students class reportedly
asked the student why if it was so bad
here he did not go to another place to
live they brought me here the boy
replied according to a statement taken
by the school's resource officers the
teacher reportedly retorted well you can
always go back because I came here from
Cuba and the day I feel I'm not welcome
here anymore I would find another place
to live at that point the substitute
teacher called the called the office
noting that she could no longer deal
with the student the school's dean of
students reportedly tried to calm the
student down but after asking a student
to leave the class 20 times to no avail
the Dean called in the students school
resource officer so this is a police
officer that's on campus to deal with
these kinds of things the school
resource officer then intervened and
asked the student eggs at the classroom
and he refused and the student left the
classroom eventually and created and
other disturbance and made threats while
he was escorted to the office according
to the arrest affidavit the student was
arrested by the school resource officer
because he refused to follow multiple
commands he repeatedly called school
leaders racist and was disruptive they
said he threatened to get the school
resource officer and principal fired and
to beat the teacher eventually the
student was placed under arrest okay so
that's the whole story
now here you could still disagree and
say he should have been arrested it
shouldn't be dealt with that way that's
fine but he was not arrested the thing
on the arrest affidavit is not gonna say
refuse to stand for the pledge that's
not the that is not the the crime that
was committed that's not a crime that's
not what he was
he was arrested because he was basically
begging for it
now of course the mother has come out
and complained that her poor innocent
innocent son is a victim you know come
to his defense and everything which is
very different from how my mom would
have responded when I see all of these
parents you know rushing to the defense
of their of their unruly disruptive kids
I all we always just had to scratch my
head because that is not how I was
raised at all that is so foreign to me
as a parent now and thinking back to my
experience as a child if I had I mean if
I had refused to listen to my teacher
which I I did that plenty of times when
I was a kid I must admit but if I had
refused to listen to my teacher to the
point where the school resource officer
had to be called in and then I still
refused to follow the instructions that
I was given and then as I was being led
away forcefully because I refused to
leave the class I threatened to
physically assault my teacher and I was
arrested for it I could tell you my mom
would not be on camera crying crocodile
tears of sympathy for me I could tell
you that right now neither with my dad
I would I would be facing whatever the
legal penalties are and school penalties
and then I would go home and I would
face even worse penalties that's what
would have happened to me but this of
course is what part of what makes the
job of teachers so difficult today is
that they have to deal with these awful
kids and they're terrible parents who
will defend they're awful kids no matter
what they're awful kids do and it's it's
it's it's it's well awful and again as a
parent myself I don't even understand
that instinct like well you know my kids
are younger but when we leave our kids
with a babysitter or something like that
because my wife's gonna go out for a
date and I go watch a movie or something
and if we ever come home and we get a
report from the babysitter that our kids
were being unruly
um disobedient disrespectful that is
going to make me very very angry and
they are going to face severe
consequences
you know on the few occasions when we've
come home and the babysitter has given
us a bad report my first instinct as a
parent is not to say oh no my little
baby never would do that it must be your
fault you're being mean too much of my
precious little babies no see that's not
my first dancing my first instinct is to
believe the adult okay does that make me
a bad parent my first instinct is to
side with the adult over my kid because
they're adults
and I know how kids are I was a kid
myself once so when I hear a story about
my kid being disrespectful I think yeah
well that's that I mean I know they can
act like that sometimes I've seen it
myself and it's totally unacceptable
and so then what will happen is I will
apologize to the adults for having to
deal with that and then I will get my
child and make them apologize here's a
here's a news flash for this precious
little snowflakes mom if if a kid is
being told to leave the classroom he
needs to leave okay if your son is being
told to leave the classroom he needs to
leave he doesn't get to refuse it's not
up to him he's not the adult he needs to
respect his elders see at this point
it's not even about the pledge it's not
about respecting the pledge or the flag
or the country it's got nothing to do
with that now now it is about listening
to and respecting the adults that's all
it's about it doesn't matter how he
feels about the pledge doesn't matter
that's fine
doesn't want to stand fine but he was
asked to leave that that substitute
teacher was put in charge of the class
for the day your son's not in charge of
the class your sixth-grade son's not in
charge
the teachers in charge that's the adult
and you as an adult should be should be
backing up the other adult in the
situation who you have entrusted your
child to see
by sending your kid to school you have
put other adults in the position of
watching your kid and and dealing with
whatever outrageous behavior your kid
decides to engage in so the least you
can do as a parent is have the other
adults backs don't send your awful kid
to school and then they act and then the
in and then they behave terribly and so
not only are you you know are you
inflicting your awful kids awful
behavior on other adults but then you're
but then you're on camera you're on TV
calling for them to be fired over it
it's your fault that your kids acting
that way teach him some respect he
doesn't get to do what he wants he
doesn't get to shut down the whole class
bring everything to a grinding halt
force everyone to deal with his temper
tantrum you know I saw this plenty when
I was in school these these kids that
would they would get upset at the
teacher for whatever reason and whether
they're right to be upset or not right
it doesn't meant that makes no
difference
but then they're asked to leave the
class because they're causing a
disruption and they refuse to leave and
they just sit there and they won't
listen and so now everybody has to stop
what we're doing we have to stop learn
English to stop everything we're doing
to deal with your kid doesn't that
embarrass you
shouldn't you be embarrassed by that as
a parent see if I was the parent I would
be humiliated I would be so embarrassed
the last thing I would want to do is be
on camera if there was a camera I put a
paper bag over my head and try to rush
to the car so that I wasn't caught on
camera I'd be so embarrassed that my kid
was doing that and you know what
wants to get real big if the kid wants
to act big act like a big boy and start
threatening start making physical
threats okay you know once you start
making physical threats uh cops not
gonna mess around with that especially
these days I don't know maybe you've
watched the news and you've seen the
stories about school shootings and stuff
like that violence in the schools yeah
guess what if you make violent threats
in a school to a teacher or to anybody
else and there's a school resource
officer there your butt's gonna get
hauled away to jail that's what's gonna
happen because they're not gonna mess
around with that they're not gonna take
any chances and they shouldn't again
this has got nothing to do with the
Pledge of Allegiance as far as the
Pledge of Allegiance go you know I I
it's it's a totally separate thing and
you know as it happens I do kind of have
an issue with the pledge but again
that's that's totally it's it's it's got
nothing to do it's a completely separate
issue because this is about respecting
elders and doing as you're told
as a child but you know there are
aspirin here's the thing even though
it's totally unrelated now that I'm on
the subject here's the thing I don't
like about the pledge there's really
just one line in the pledge not only and
I know these days the people that there
are a lot of people don't like the under
god part no I like that part that part
is good there's one line in the pledge I
really don't like and that is
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
now I like liberty and justice that part
I like that's good but indivisible see I
I disagree with that I don't think the
country is indivisible
I think that's incorrect because I
believe in states rights so the state of
Texas for instance is not owned by the
federal government
it is not owned by the collective it is
not an indivisible part of the United
States it has the right or it should
have the right I believe personally to
leave if it wants to so at the very
least the idea of an indivisible country
is is controversial I mean we fought a
war over it for goodness sake it is not
a universally accepted thing
yeah we have our kids stand up and say
indivisible without encouraging them to
think about what that means and whether
or not they even agree with it because
that's it again that's an opinion and
not a not a universally held opinion
that the country is an indivisible whole
and it cannot be divided up so at the
very least if we're gonna have our kids
stand up and say this every morning they
should be encouraged to think about it
and to be and to be you know to be
analytical but anyway that's that's
beside the point
the real point again is do as you're
told as a child in school finally before
we get to emails okay I almost forgot
this I got to talk about this I need to
show you something
and I want you to prepare yourself
because this is very disturbing
all right I was I happen to swing by the
grocery store yesterday I went to giant
supermarket and as I was walking in I
was immediately greeted by this look at
this picture now I want to leave this
picture up on the screen for a bit
because I want you to really soak this
in okay that is a robot that you're
looking at right now that is a robot
called Marty the robot I read this I'm
not kidding I really this was at the
grocery store and it moves around the
store if it's it's got it's on wheels
you can't see the whole thing in the
picture I took but it is uh it is I was
afraid to approach it on this I don't
know if it's gonna you know zap me with
a laser beam or something but it is it's
on wheels and it just it moves around
the store this robot I was in the
produce section I was trying to find
avocados of course because I'm a
millennial
and the thing was blocking the avocados
and I'm like robot please get Marta
excuse me so it moves around the store
looking for shoplifters and if it finds
a shoplifter it shoots anthrax in its
face no actually that's not technically
correct it's it says that there's a
little sign oh it says that it's looking
for spills to clean up but I swear this
thing followed me around the store with
it's huge dead googly eyes look at those
eyes you're staring at the apocalypse
folks
alright the end of all things this is
how it ends first they're cleaning up
broken jars of mayonnaise in Aisle 12
and next thing you know Marty and his
robot camp a tree 'it's are enslaving
mankind so beware all right let's get to
some of your some of your emails you can
email the show Matt wall show at
gmail.com Matt well show at gmail.com
this is from cheerily cheerily I think
is how you pronounce the name great name
by the way says I love your show he
listened to all all the episodes yours
Andrew Michael and Ben in the morning on
my commute to work
I would there must be a long commute by
the way I would like to thank you and
the others for doing what you do and
helping me get through my day from
dealing with health care being a write
to the Mary Poppins books being racist
because the chimney sweep is doing
blackface in some fashion
you guys keep me grounded in sanity
thank you seriously thank you I hope you
have a wonderful day god bless thank you
Cheerilee for watching all the shows in
your commute or listening to them anyway
hope you listen to them and not watch
them if you're driving this is from
Jared it says it seems that you are an
effing idiot seems seei I appreciate
that little so you hedge your bets a
little bit there seems that I'm an
effing idiot
seems but looks can be deceiving
Jared this is from Dustin and says hi
Matt just listen to today's show I like
you am on the fence about the death
penalty I would hate to be in a position
where I had to make such a decision
either as a juror or a prosecutor
however a part of my concern about the
death penalty is that it actually costs
more to execute someone that it does to
incarcerate them for life trials where
the death penalty is sawn also cost more
a quick Google search will net you at
least a few scholarly articles on the
topic thanks for all you do get with the
good work
yeah that's true Dustin the people
people death penalty opponents will trot
out that fact quite often but the thing
is that the when we talk about the death
penalty being more expensive first of
all I don't you know this doesn't really
come down to cost per se
um but it also has an inflated
artificial cost because the cost comes
from all the appeals and all the years
on death row and everything doesn't have
to be that way
I mean carrying out a death sentence can
be a rather cheap and simple process and
I think we make it a lot more
complicated than it needs to be so you
know that is just something to keep in
mind every time you hear about how
expensive it is this is from Andy it
says hey Matt I listen to a podcast
about Munchausen's syndrome the other
day so it got me thinking with regards
to a seeming increase in faked hate
crimes sexual assault allegations and
racism claims over the last decade or so
I wonder if this could be an unintended
consequence of social media that leads
to some sort of Munchausen type problem
in our inwardly focused society I say
this not as an expert by any stretch but
because there seems to be similarities
in these two phenomenon just as people
with Munchausen's syndrome
make themselves sick or injure
themselves mainly for attention or
sympathy people make up these
accusations because they know that the
media and Twitter will rush to pay
attention to them and feel sorry for
them without the need for evidence or a
backstory about the event I may be just
trying to connect the two unrelated dots
of my dislike of social media and these
allegations that keep coming out but I
just want to share my two sons I think
you're exactly right Andy that's a very
good point that I wish I had thought of
myself Munchausen it is kind of my
childhood syndrome I think it's sort of
a sort of exactly it's it's the
motivations are exactly the same my only
problem is when you attach a word like
syndrome to something you make it into a
disease or disorder or that whatever now
it seems like you are which I know isn't
your intention but part of the effect is
removing the accountability from the
person who's doing it which of course we
can't do because it's still their fault
it's it's a choice that they've made to
make up these stories and they should
face the consequences for that all right
finally this is what I really wanted to
get to from this is from grace I
mentioned this on the show yesterday
gonna respond to this question here's
the question again says hi Matt I've
been wanting to know your opinion about
something sometimes I will hear
Christian apologist argue the case for
Christianity on the basis of near-death
experiences they point to all the
stories of people being medically dead
and then experiencing a vision of Christ
or heaven do you think this is an
effective argument what is your position
on NDEs NDE near-death experience ah hi
grace that's a great question I thank
you for it I here's the thing you know I
thought a lot about this and I I differ
from a lot of my fellow Christians on
this point I don't think that near-death
experiences are a great apologetic tool
and more to the point I am skeptical of
every near-death experience story I've
ever heard about which isn't to say that
I think people are lying I think that
they really did experience something
that's just they might be
misinterpreting their experience the
question is whether or not these
experiences people have where they you
know are near-death or sometimes the
claim that they medically died or
whatever on the operating table and then
they went to heaven or they saw Jesus or
they saw their dead relatives or
what-have-you and then they woke up
again I don't doubt that these people
saw the things that they thought they
saw what the question is is it a
psychological phenomenon or did it
actually happen and I tend to think it's
more psychological and I'll tell you
what number one and this to me is the
main thing that I can't really get
around near-death experiences are common
among all types of people of all faiths
all over the world
now if only Christians had these
experiences or if Christians were much
more likely to have them then maybe I'd
say that there's something there but
that's not the case there's no evidence
of that so all kinds of people all over
the world what have these well what does
that mean it means that Muslims who have
n B's will have Islamic visions of the
afterlife and Hindus will have Hindu
visions and Buddhists will have visions
consistent with that philosophy seeks
the same thing
etc so if if the experience that someone
has in a near that near-death experience
is actually real as in they are really
seeing the afterlife then how do we
explain the Hindu who goes off and meets
Vishnu how do we explain the Native
American who in a case that I read about
recently went to the sky and convened
with a council of elders in the in the
sky in the clouds it seems that as
Christians we must either assume that
all non-christian NDEs are false or
demonic which i think would be a silly
assumption and definitely a case of
special pleading or we must say that all
religions are right so they really are
all you know so so all visions of the
afterlife in the end they're all right
they're all exactly they all whatever
your vision is of the afterlife that's
where you go which we know as Christians
is not the case or well you know I'm not
sure what else you do with this fact it
if you want to believe that n DS are
real things you're experiencing
something real and really seeing the
afterlife then I'm not sure what you do
with all of these conflicting
experiences of the afterlife that people
have based on their religious faith
unless you conclude that n DS are a
neurological phenomenon essentially a
hallucination like a dream that reflects
whatever ideas and beliefs the person
had the person having the experience
already held see that's the only
conclusion I think sufficiently accounts
for the prevalence of these experiences
among all religions second thing people
have claimed to be on the operating
table and like hovering above their body
or they've claimed to teleport to other
places in the hospital or or
what-have-you but studies have been done
controlled studies to try and replicate
and test these stories because they are
very impressive stories but they're just
stories in the end right and when there
have been when there have been attempts
to actually in real time
these stories they never they always
fail so for instance I heard about a I
heard about a study that was done at
some point where I think it was like a a
word was written on a sticky note and it
was put on a high filing cabinet in a in
an operating room you know put up really
high so you couldn't see it unless
you're on a ladder and then when people
came back from their near-death
experiences and they claim that they
were hovering above their bodies and
hovering above the room they were asked
well what's the word on the note did you
see the word up there or not you should
have been able to see it what did it say
and nobody could say no because in this
controlled environment all of a sudden
these stories kind of aren't as
impressive anymore which I think tells
us something and you know not to mention
just metaphysically just it doesn't
really make sense to me like you're on
the operating table and what your soul
gets up and goes for a jog around the
hospital so your body for that period is
soulless what does that has it even work
what why would that even happen like why
would your soul slip away for a minute
like you're falling out of your shoes or
something and then your soul just
wanders back it really it kind of just
doesn't make any sense to me and the
third thing is that near-death
experiences are they're just that okay
they're near-death so the people who say
oh I died for 10 minutes on the
operating table because their heart
stopped or they stopped breathing well
that's not actually true they did not
die they were still alive although
barely which again is a problem with
them saying that their soul went away
and flew around the hospital because
they're not actually dead so how does
that work did their soul split in two or
when there or were they living when they
were living they were just a soulless
husk for that period of time and their
soul was off somewhere else that seems
to raise all kinds of problems because
no they did not die when somebody says
oh I died for five minutes I came back I
went to heaven I came back no you didn't
you didn't die I mean I you know I'm not
discounting the severity of your medical
emergency at all I'm just saying that
you did not die you were not actually
medically dead
because to be dead is when all brain
activity ceases there is no more brain
activity there was nothing you are just
a husk a corpse laying there that's dead
you are dead when you are a corpse and
the thing is if you're a corpse and you
go to heaven and you come back that's
not a near-death experience you're
claiming that you were resurrected that
is a resurrection you are claiming to
have been resurrected from the dead like
Jesus and I'm not saying that's
impossible we know what happened to
Jesus and we know Jesus raised Lazarus
rat Lazarus from the dead but I'm just
saying that is a that is a very
different kind of claim and it's one
that I am skeptical of because according
to these stories it seems like people
are being resurrected left and right
like it's not even a big deal to be
resurrected and then the fourth thing
this this is kind of a more minor
objection but you know I can't help but
notice that all of these people who go
to heaven and then come back they never
seem to have anything really urgent or
startling or insightful or surprising to
say right I mean it seems like if God if
God's gonna send you back from heaven
which actually is it's I mean that's
kind of a bummer right the - you were in
heaven you're in eternal paradise and
now you have to come back that's not
it's not really a positive thing so it
seems like if God's gonna send you back
from heaven there would be a really good
reason for it like you've got a really
important message to share but nobody
ever comes back from heaven with the
cure for cancer
nobody ever even really comes back with
any sort of penetrating profound insight
it's just now they come back with a
beautiful story and very inspiring but
they come back and they write a book for
it and they get three you know they they
sell three million copies and all of
that but is that why God sent them back
so they could write a best-selling book
which will then enter into a whole genre
now of I went to heaven
there's old genre of books now the I
went to heaven genre so it's what it's a
routine the currents now God is just
sending people back from heaven left and
right just so they can share some pretty
cliched message about make the most of
life and all that love your family I
mean yeah that's it I am NOT yeah it's
true we should make the most of life and
we should love our families but does God
need to send anyone back from heaven to
say that so I don't know if somebody
came back from heaven supposedly with
something to say that was really so
incredible and surprising and
inexplicable that it you know it can't
be explained on the other way then you
know they they went to heaven and
received a divine message if that word
ever happened in modern day then I would
feel differently but I'm not aware of
any cases like that
so the answer is uh as no unfortunately
I you know I know people it's very
comforting to think about near-death
experiences I I know people that have
had these experiences there's nothing I
can say to dissuade them I'm not trying
to dissuade them I'm just giving my own
personal opinion on the topic and that's
what it is thank you for the question
thanks everybody for listening thank you
for being here
Godspeed